[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia con quien vamos a hablar de
un tema recurrente durante esta pandemia
de coronavirus y es la carrera por la
vacuna doctor los saludo esta semana se
publicaron varias noticias relacionadas
con los diferentes laboratorios que
trabajan en contrarreloj en materia de
vacunas en eeuu por ejemplo el
laboratorio pzifer informó que su vacuna
había superado el 90 por ciento de
efectividad en las pruebas realizadas a
más de 40 mil personas a lo cual anthony
fauci del experto en infecciones de eeuu
se mostró sorprendido que tanta
confianza se puede tener en esta vacuna
los resultados que se esperaban era que
superará el 90% el 50 por ciento sesenta
por ciento es decir lo mínimo que
esperaba la organización mundial de la
salud destinado a proteger el 60 por
ciento en la noticia de que sea 90 por
ciento realmente no sorprende a todos
porque habla una alta efectividad ahora
estamos en el período de evaluar la
seguridad y digamos que es una buena
noticia porque impactaría positivamente
las personas que se vacunen a todos
nosotros doctor esta vacuna pzifer
espera por la aprobación de emergencia
que le dé la fd a cuáles son los
protocolos que requiere esta vacuna para
obtener luz verde de para la etapa de
producción
las vacunas tienen varias fases una fase
experimentación una fase de aplicación
en pequeños grupos humanos una fase
donde se masifica que lo que se llama
fase 3 es la que está culminando con las
vacunas de facer y la fase 4 que es la
fase ya implementación y post mercado
esta fase 3 es muy importante porque
determina la seguridad cuando termina la
fase 3 se somete a las entidades
regulatorias las entidades regulatorias
revisan los datos dicen es una vacuna
segura y se procede a probable una vez
aprobada los gobiernos pueden adquirirla
y nosotros podríamos vacunarnos ahora
doctor a la par con la vacuna de facer
en la vacuna rusa sputnik 5 podría tener
el 92 por ciento de efectividad según
afirmaron las autoridades rusas se puede
confiar en esta vacuna
realmente lo que tenemos que confiar en
es en los datos en los hechos en las
publicaciones que sean revisadas por
pares independientes académicos estas
vacunas la de fases o de cualquier
industria farmacéutica no es valorada
solamente por la industria que lo
propone pero son varios grupos de
expertos que validan que si sirve con la
vacuna rusa tenemos la expectativa de
que pueda ser validada y que los datos
que comenta el gobierno pues sean
verificados por científicos lo que
necesitamos ahora es el mayor número de
vacunas que sean accesibles y que sean
disponibles pero necesitamos hechos para
demostrar la seguridad ahora de otra
parte esta semana en brasil se
interrumpieron las pruebas de la vacuna
china de sinovac por lo que llamaron un
incidente adverso grave que se entiende
por este incidente adverso grave en una
fase de pruebas
durante esta fase 3 se lo que se hacen
son ensayos y cuando algo no sale bien
se separan independientemente si primero
se evalúa si recibió la vacuna o el
placebo recuerde en este momento un
agente está reviendo la vacuna y otra no
está recién de la cual está recibiendo
un placer un comité experto evalúe ese
evento y dice es atribuible o no a la
vacuna si no es atribuirle procede en
las últimas horas ya se volvió otra vez
a reactivar y la vacunación en brazos de
sinovac ahora hay que personas serán las
primeras en vacunarse las personas
recuperadas de ccoo y 19 también se
podrían vacunar doctor yo creo que la
buena perspectiva es que si se logró una
vacuna y que es efectiva como nos vamos
a vacunar te van a priorizar grupos de
riesgo trabajadores de la salud van a
hacer poblaciones de alto riesgo de
mortalidad como personas obesas
hipertensas con antecedentes de
enfermedad pulmonar y cada uno de los
gobiernos tiene que diseñar la logística
la priorización
vamos adelante el hecho de que haya una
vacuna y que haya salido con la
perspectiva hable ahora el nuevo reto de
los gobiernos que es la implementación y
la accesibilidad y creo que todos
tenemos que estar supervisando apoyando
para que todos logremos la vacunación
doctor gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros una vez más aquí en
france24 esto fue cinco minutos con
hasta una próxima oportunidad
[Música]